In true Marvel fashion, Captain Marvel's cast
is packed with fan-favorite actors.
Alongside them is up-and-coming star Gemma
Chan, playing Starforce member Minn-Erva.
Chan has risen through the ranks of British
television and film before appearing in a
few worldwide blockbusters.
Here's where you've spotted her over the years.
In 2009, Chan scored her first major credit
by appearing in a special episode of Doctor
Who alongside the popular Tenth Doctor, played
by David Tennant . "The Waters of Mars," which
won a Hugo Award, is set on the red planet
in 2059, where the Doctor encounters a human
colony which is endangered by his presence.
Chan plays Mia Bennett, a geologist, who survives
the Doctor's unintentional meddling with the
structure of time.
Chan didn't have a lot of screentime, but
the episode, which was one of Tennant's final
outings as the Doctor, was well-received,
setting her up for more roles in the future.
A popular British sitcom that aired for four
series from 2006 to 2010, The IT Crowd revolved
around three main characters, each of whom
brings different neuroses to their roles as
tech support for a major company.
Chan appeared in two different episodes as
two different characters - after a brief initial
appearance in the 2010 episode "The Final
Countdown," she reappeared in "Reynholm vs.
Reynholm" that same year, playing a Female
Sulu in a Star Trek parody.
Chan followed up this appearance with a role
in the BBC series Sherlock, which stars Benedict
Cumberbatch and Martin Freeman as Holmes and
Watson, respectively.
The hit show formats each classic Arthur Conan
Doyle story about the famous detective into
long installments that deliver a modern twist
on the tale.
Chan appeared in the 2010 episode "The Blind
Banker" as Soo Lin Yao, a Chinese pottery
expert working at a museum who disappears
and turns out to have a dark past.
"Some things aren't supposed to sit behind
glass.
They're made to be touched, to be handled."
After smaller films and some guest spots,
Chan finally found a few recurring roles on
television shows, cementing herself as a star
on the rise.
After her appearance on Sherlock in 2011,
Chan scored a series regular role in the fourth
series of Secret Diary of a Call Girl, which
was broadcast in both the U.K. and the U.S.
Starring Billie Piper, best known for her
companion role alongside David Tennant on
Doctor Who, the show centered on Hannah, a
normal London girl by day who works as a call
girl at night to pay her bills.
As her two lives continue to collide, she
meets new girls at the agency at which she
is employed, and that's where Chan comes in.
During the fourth series of the show, she
played Charlotte, a haughty escort working
for the agency who is strident and always
gets what she wants.
Chan followed up this huge role with a regular
spot on Bedlam, a British sci-fi drama, during
the show's second series.
Starring Theo James, Bedlam tells the story
of Bedlam Heights, a run-down complex of apartments
home to a series of strange hauntings.
Chan appeared as Keira, a childhood friend
of a character from the first series who serves
as a confidant for Ellie, the de facto lead
of the second series.
"We've been drinking.
It isn't safe to be in the pool."
"Paramedics and fun really don't mix."
Chan's first blockbuster breakout came in
Jack Ryan: Shadow Recruit in 2014.
She appeared alongside Chris Pine as the namesake
CIA agent, Kevin Costner as the CIA official
who recruits him, director Kenneth Branagh
as a Russian tycoon, and Keira Knightley as
a medical student and Ryan's fianceé.
Chan played Amy Chang, a fellow spy on Ryan's
team who proves herself to be an incredibly
competent ally.
An extension of the Harry Potter universe,
Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find Them was
released to eager fans in 2016, moving the
magical world from the U.K. to the United
States during the 1920s.
The movie introduces audiences to Newt Scamander
played by Oscar winner Eddie Redmayne, a "magizoologist".
Chan played Madam Ya Zhou, a member of the
International Confederation of Wizards.
"You know which of your creatures was responsible,
Mr. Scamander?"
"No creature did this."
The film was a commercial smash, grossing
a total of $814 million, and was hailed by
most critics as a promising start to a new
franchise within the already wildly popular
world of Harry Potter.
Though Chan did not appear in the 2018 sequel,
her role in such a massive blockbuster set
her up for even more film success.
Chan returned to a regular television role
in Humans, a British series for Channel 4
that aired between 2015 and 2018 and was also
broadcast on the American network AMC.
Based on a Swedish show called Real Humans,
the series featured a world filled with hyper-realistic
robots called "synths."
Chan played a synth hired by a human family
to work as a nanny.
Throughout her three seasons on the show,
Chan's standout performance attracted plenty
of positive attention.
Chan's biggest role yet came in 2018's Crazy
Rich Asians, the breakout hit adapted from
Kevin Kwan's bestselling novel of the same
name.
As the first film since 1993's The Joy Luck
Club to feature an all-Asian cast and an Asian-American
lead, the film was both a critical and a commercial
success.
Chan played Astrid, a fabulously rich and
impeccably accomplished socialite who is so
successful and worldly that her husband has
grown resentful.
Thanks to the first film's success, two sequels
are already in the works, and a mid-credits
scene indicated that one may focus heavily
on Astrid, as it shows her locking eyes with
a mysterious man at a luxurious party.
2018's Mary Queen of Scots is a historical
drama based on the conflict between cousins
Mary and Elizabeth I to secure the throne
of England.
Director Josie Rourke staged a soapy, feminist
spectacle with some groundbreaking casting
choices, including Chan's role.
Chan played Bess of Hardwick, a close friend
of Elizabeth I who not only acted as the Virgin
Queen's confidante, but, alongside her husband,
helped keep Mary captive for 15 years.
Even though Chan's casting was technically
historically inaccurate, Rourke insisted on
color-blind casting, giving Chan an opportunity
to make a big impression before her debut
in the MCU.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Marvel characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.